*musique stylée*
J'ai mon billet pour aller en apesanteur !
Nous sommes cette fois à Bordeaux, et pas en Allemagne.
C'est la suite de la dernière vidéo qu'on avait fait à l'agence spatiale européenne.
On avait fait l'entraînement d'un astronaute, et maintenant on va aller dans l'espace, ou plutôt on va simuler un espace où il n'y a pas de gravité.
Comment on va faire ça, je vais vous expliquer. On va prendre cet avion qui est derrière moi et on va faire ce qu'on appelle "des paraboles".
C'est-à-dire qu'on va monter, puis redescendre, et y aura une phase où on subira 1,8 fois la gravité terrestre
Par exemple, au lieu de peser 30 kilos, j'en pèserai 60.
Si t'as vraiment cru que je pesais 30 kilos t'es un bâtard.
Ce qui fait que ce sera assez dur physiquement, surtout au niveau de l'oreille interne, en fait.
Du coup j'ai ce petit cachet, qui va finalement me droguer l'oreille interne.
Vous savez, c'est un peu comme ce que vous prenez quand vous avez le mal des transports, bah ça va beaucoup m'aider pendant le vol et il faut que je le prenne maintenant.
Pour revenir aux paraboles, c'est extrêmement simple,  en gros l'avion fait comme quand tu dois allez au Maroc ou aux USA l'été prochain.
Il fait une bonne ligne droite, donc là il y a une gravité normale dans l'avion, comme quand on est sur Terre,
puis il va se mettre à monter, et c'est à ce moment-là qu'on va entrer dans une phase où on va subir 1,8 fois la gravité terrestre.
Et au milieu de la montée, c'est là qu'il n'y aura plus de gravité
Bon, même si les puristes diront qu'en vrai, on est quand même soumis à une gravité, mais on la ressent pas vraiment.
Ça durera jusqu'en haut, puis un peu dans la descente, et là on va repasser à 1,8 g.
Et rebelote, et rebelote, on va faire ça quinze fois, donc je vais me bouffer quinze fois le double de la gravité terrestre,
et quinze fois aucune gravité. Ça va être incroyable, en plus ils ont prévu plein de choses à faire dans l'avion, ça va être super.
Merci Mass Effect, ça va être fou, c'est parti !
*musique*
Les amis je suis dans l'avion, on vient de se faire briefer, on a un petit planning, qui est marqué juste ici
Donc les premières paraboles on va juste découvrir un peu la sensation, parce qu'on est des petits nouveaux dans le milieu du 0g
Ici, on va essayer de faire Zenyatta, apparemment.
Ici, ils vont nous montrer ce que ça donne de l'eau en apesanteur. Ça fait une sorte de sphère, c'est hyper beau.
Ici, on va tous se serrer les bras. Ça va faire une sorte d'anneau géant, ils vont nous soulever et nous faire tourner sur nous-mêmes, ça va être assez impressionnant.
En fait, toutes les paraboles vont être en 0g, sauf 3, il y aura 3 fois où ce sera pas de la 0g.
Une première fois, on va simuler la gravité de Mars, et on va en profiter pour faire des pompes. C'est un tiers de la gravité terrestre, la gravité de Mars.
Puis les deux paraboles suivantes ce sera la gravité de la Lune, et là ce sera un sixième de la gravité terrestre.
Ça veut dire qu'en gros, t'es à peine ramené au sol, donc tu peux faire un peu ce que tu veux : des pompes à un doigt,
se suspendre ici et faire de la gym... Y a pas de souci !
Ce sera bien la première fois de ma vie qu'on pourra faire des choses d'homme musclé, hein !
Et ensuite on va pouvoir jouer avec des balles ! Et ce sera là aussi la première fois de ma vie que j'arriverai à jongler, incroyable !
*bruit d'avion et musique*
Vladimir, qui est notre moniteur, nous a expliqué que quand on va entrer dans la phase qui est soumise à 1,8 fois la gravité terrestre,
on va s'allonger par terre, comme des bâtons, pour ne pas être mal.
*musique effrayante*
Et en fait, il nous a expliqué qu'il faut qu'on fixe un point, et si tu bouges ta tête, le signal que ton oreille interne va envoyer à ton cerveau va être décuplé, et ça va être la merde.
Ok c'est parti on se lève, et on va dans notre zone. ¡Vamos David! ¡Vamos!
On est tout au bout de l'avion, juste à côté des pilotes. On va pas tarder à s'allonger.
Ah ça vlog ! Ca vlog dans tous les sens !
Les amis petite surprise, on va pouvoir tester... Un hand spinner que Nozman m'a gentiment prêté ! En 0g, qu'est-ce que ça va donner ?
On verra tout à l'heure !
Oh le mec qui met du suspense dans sa vidéo !
- T'es excité, t'as hâte ?
- Ah ouais, ouais !
Eh Vladimir est en train de danser depuis tout à l'heure ! *rire*
Les amis il est temps de s'allonger ! Je vous dis à tout de suite !
Je suis obligé de mettre le bras le long de mon corps, je vous quitte ! Adieu !
Ok les amis ! On est en train de voler, on est en apesanteur !!
WOOUUUH !!
WOUUH !! Holy shit !
Woh les gars ! Oh I'm sorry !
Les amis c'est juste dingue !
Je peux tourner sur moi-même !!
Même pour s'allonger mec, ça va tellement vite !
Wooh ! C'est comme si en 2g, tout était plus rapide !
C'est impressionnant, mec ! Je me sens vide !
C'est comme si t'étais plus en vie, c'est hyper bizarre !
En fait quand t'es en 0g, à peine tu mets un peu de puissance, à peine tu mets un petit coup par terre, et tu vas tout de suite décoller en fait !
Et personne n'avait pris ça en compte, donc on s'est tous pris le plafond direct !
J'ai aucun mot pour décrire ce que je ressens. C'est juste... incroyable.
Ca se voit que ça fait des millions d'années que l'humain vit avec la gravité : même notre cerveau il est pas prêt à ça en fait.
Même la 2g c'est une sensation de dingue ! Est-ce que vous êtes prêts à décoller ?
C'est parti.
Ok, y a plus de gravité. On est en train de voler.
Ok, j'essaie de contrôler un peu... J'vais pas vous mentir...
Je suis en train de tourner sur moi-même.
Je m'en bats les couilles, je suis un singe !
-Il est en train de mourir ! Are you dying ?
-Yes ! (Squeezie rit). I lost my ...
J'ai la caméra de David ! Et il a ma caméra !
*exclamations de Squeezie et des autres passagers*
Ca passe très très vite ! On est déjà à la 4ème parabole.
Mes amis, je suis bouche bée. En fait, tu ne peux absolument pas contrôler tes mouvements.
On passe des mois à apprendre à marcher, et là c'est comme repartir de zéro.
On va se mettre d'un côté de l'avion, et ils vont envoyer de l'eau en apesanteur sur nous, ça va être assez ouf.
OOOH !! Amazing !
C'est bon. Oh putain ça coule du coup.
C'était l'une des plus belles choses que j'ai vues de ma vie, je crois.
De l'eau qui vole, mec. C'est con, mais c'est d'une beauté ! C'est ouf.
A la prochaine, les amis, on va faire tourner le hand spinner.
C'est parti.
C'est dingue !
Le truc ne bouge pas ! Ow, shit !
C'est dingue ! Oh putain !
Le truc descend un peu mais pas trop, quoi.
On aura vu ce que ça donne, un hand spinner en l'air !
On est à la moitié du vol, et on va maintenant faire l'anneau. On va tous se coller et ils vont nous faire tourner sur nous-mêmes.
*musique douce, rires et exclamations*
Les amis, vous croyez tous que je n'ai pas de biceps ! Eh bien c'est faux et je vais vous le prouver.
Qui n'a pas de muscles putain ?
Tranquillement, y a pas de souci. J'peux me gratter.
A un doigt, je vais une pompe à un doigt ! Alors, qui est pas musclé ?
Eh ben, je veux aller vivre sur Mars, tout simplement !
On va maintenant passer à une simulation de la pesanteur lunaire !
Ce qui veut dire que tu fais un sixième de ton poids !
Wooh ! Woh, tu voles, mais légèrement !
On y vaaaaaa !!
Attention, ce flip arrière !
Youhouuuu !!
C'est n'importe quoi !
Les amis on va tenter le passage en 2g en étant debout, il faut que je contracte mes petites cuisses à fond.
C'est parti. Tout le sang va dans mes jambes, les amis ! C'est un délire !
Je vais essayer de me mettre là-haut !
Et voilà mon gars ! On y est ! On est au plafond putain !
Ça va ? *rire*
C'est les deux ou trois dernières paraboles, je suis hyper triste. Et je commençais seulement à contrôler un peu mes mouvements.
On va pouvoir jouer avec des balles ! Je vais vous montrer en 2g à quel point ça redescend plus vite.
Donc, gravité terrestre, et regardez là on va passer en 2g.
C'est parti, 2g !
Regardez comme ça descend plus vite ! Ça n'a aucun sens, ce qui se passe !
Ok, c'est parti, on va s'asseoir au plafond.
Et voilà les amis. On est assis au plafond. C'est incroyable !
Ma tête pèse actuellement 20 kilos. On peut dire que j'ai pris la grosse tête !!
C'est incroyable ! Avec les boules qui volent !
Vladimir m'a parlé d'un jeu très dangereux. On fait le jeu de la mort, c'est la dernière ! On le fait ensemble ?
(Squeezie) - Avec Vladimir on va faire le jeu de la mort, on va se tenir, on va se laisser tomber en avant.
(Vladimir) - On va pas se tenir !
(Squeezie) - Si si on va se tenir, on va se tenir, mais bien sûr, Vladimir !
On va se laisser tomber en avant pendant que ce sera 1,8g, et on va prier pour que la 0g arrive pendant notre chute.
T'es chaud ? *rire*
J'ai très peur. Si on se foire, on va se prendre le sol, mais d'une violence...
De toute façon, moi je te suis hein. Dès que tu commences à tomber, je fais comme toi !
Ok, tu me dis quand on tombe, Vladimir !!
C'est dur de tenir debout, déjà !
*BOUM*
OH LE CON !
Oh le con ! Il s'est foiré !
Oh merde ! *rire*
Il a fait exprès de se foirer ! J'me suis pris le sol, mais d'une violence ! Oh merde !
C'est la fin !
Wouuuh !! Merci le pilote !
Incroyable ! Incroyable !
Les amis, c'est terminé, il est maintenant temps de s'en aller.
Je réalise à peine ce qui vient de nous arriver, c'était... C'était ouf.
J'espère que j'ai vraiment réussi à vous transmettre un peu ce que j'ai pu ressentir durant ce vol,
grâce à cette putain de GoPro.
C'est... Je n'arrive pas à le décrire, quelles sensations ça procure, tellement c'est au-delà de ce que tu peux imaginer, en fait.
Quoi qu'il en soit, merci à vous, puisque c'est grâce à vous que j'ai pu faire ce vol 0g.
Merci à Electronic Arts de m'avoir envoyé ici,
Et merci à toute la team Novespace, qui était absolument adorable et qui m'ont mis en confiance,
parce qu'il faut savoir qu'à la base, j'ai peur de l'avion, et je crois que c'est le vol où j'ai le moins eu peur de ma vie !
J'avais vraiment pas peur du tout, j'étais carrément serein.
Et je pense que ça m'a beaucoup aidé à supporter le vol en lui-même, parce qu'en vrai c'est assez éprouvant, tu fais quand même 1,8g,
puis 0g, puis 1,8g, puis 0g. Ton corps à chaque fois doit s'adapter, et c'est ça qui est très fatigant, là je suis très fatigué.
Je pense que je vais en rêver cette nuit. D'ailleurs ils m'ont tous dit "tu verras, tu vas en rêver cette nuit, tellement c'était dingue."
C'est juste... Tu voles, quoi. Tu voles. C'est incroyable.
Et là, à froid, j'ai envie de regarder les images et par procuration, de ressentir à nouveau ce que j'ai ressenti dans l'avion, mais j'y arriverai pas, c'est impossible.
Je vous dis à bientôt, je m'appuie contre ce poteau comme un bon loser.
Merci pour tout, et merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo, n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu comme d'habitude.
Et puis à bientôt sur Internet. Au revoir !